you
[Music]
okay so next up is Jeff Gordon Jeff
Gordon is MSR Montreal and also a
professor at Carnegie Mellon and he's
gonna he's not gonna talk about quantum
stuff which seems cool but this also
seems cool is it gonna tell us about
learning for a policy improvement thank
you and I am happy to talk quantum with
anyone in the break it's just that it
wasn't quite ready for like actual
slides so yeah so this talk is about a
problem that I think is also important
which is learning from less than a
billion examples when you're trying to
do reinforcement learning so we all know
about the billion example successes of
RL and they're great but what if
experience is really expensive so there
are obvious cases where this is true
like a robot in the real world or safety
but maybe less obvious is like for
example personalization I was trying to
do RL for a personalization task
actually just this past week and you
know you can't wait until the person's
been using your system for seven years
before you offer personalized
suggestions right it just doesn't work
that way and so what I'm gonna what I'm
gonna propose here is to replace sort of
SGD like algorithms like policy gradient
or DQM with algorithms that are based on
policy iteration to get a different
trade off between computation and data
and so there's no free lunch we're not
going to be able to do away with the
need for data entirely but we're gonna
hope to make more efficient use of the
data that we have and as sort of
motivation consider something weird
about TV lambda so TD lambda is great as
well but if you think about it every
time it does another step of stochastic
gradient descent it has to get one new
experience right one new transition in
the world per step of optimization and
so that couples optimization with data
collection and so if your optimizer
happens to be slow as SGD
sometimes is then you use more data and
there's not really any reason why that
has to be true
so what if we did more computation on a
mini batch of samples in order to
determine a better update direction
right if we if we do it well we collect
a you know a perfectly sized mini batch
we do you know a fair bit of computation
on it because it's worth that if the
data is expensive and then we update you
know to a policy that's farther away
from where we currently are so what does
that look like so the exact policy
iteration algorithm looks like this we
alternate alternately evaluate our
policy and improve it so what so in
order to evaluate for every state action
pair we run our policy a whole bunch of
time starting with that state action
pair and calculated the Akali the
expected total cost that's Q of Si and
value is the expectation over the
actions that we take of that Q so it's a
state value and then the advantage is
the difference between the value for
taking a given action and the value that
we get on average over that state and so
it can be either advantage or
disadvantage an action could be better
or worse than than our current policy
and then for every state in parallel we
pick the best action the one with the
best advantage and we switch to it now
this is great if we're in a small
problem but in a real sized problem we
can't afford to iterate over every state
action pair and we also can't calculate
the advantage exactly we have to
estimate it somehow and we also can't
policy freely because we have to work in
some hypothesis class of possible
policies so what do we do instead so
here's a met algorithm this is not an
actual algorithm we can alternate again
between evaluation and improvement steps
and an evaluation we're going to use
some kind of function approximation to
estimate our advantage function and some
other kind of function approximation to
a
she've low to train a policy that
achieves good advantage and then we're
gonna do improvement we're going to
adjust our policy towards this new
better policy and so this is a meta
algorithm because we have to specify how
we're going to do the estimation of
advantages how we're going to train and
how we're gonna make our make our steps
but at this level of detail we can
already do a simple analysis of
approximate policy iteration one is so
that the the observation is that it's
basically for free from the performance
difference lemma that the cost of the
new policy has this I can't get a
alright I'm gonna have to do the
old-fashioned kind which also is working
all right I'm gonna wave my arms the
cost of the new policy is that
expression right there which is we get
it the PI of s0 is what we get for
following our old policy starting from
our initial state and then every time we
take an action that differs from our
policy we gain or lose according to the
advantage of that action so if we do it
T times we get T times the expectation
of that advantage right and so what that
means is that if we have gotten a policy
whose expected advantage has the correct
sign we do better right and so that
happens when our policy isn't already
optimal our hypothesis class is rich
enough to represent such a better policy
and our training actually succeeds now
there's a there's a small problem which
is the expectation we're taking here is
under the distribution of the new policy
not the distribution that we use to
collect data and so there's a difficulty
there but we can still develop
algorithms that guarantee improvement so
there's two sort of qualitative ways to
improvement they correspond to the
of algorithms that I was describing in
an SGD like algorithm we make small
updates and then if the new policy is
close enough to the old because we made
a small update then the difference
between the new and old improvement
directions doesn't matter and the
advantage of that is that we make
frequent updates we keep compiling
information into our policy and that's
great but it has the disadvantages that
I mentioned on the other hand if somehow
through some other mechanism we can
guarantee that we have a good advantage
it doesn't matter how close the the old
and new policies are and so the
advantage here is that we might be able
to spend more time optimizing each
mini-batch this gives us a range of
algorithms from aggressive to deliberate
so let's look at some algorithms that
actually can be instances of this met
algorithm and there are some old ones
and some new ones so natural policy
gradient turns out you can put it in
this framework suppose that we represent
our policy with an exponential family
and our evaluation step is to fit our
advantage function by regression we have
to use compatible function approximation
right this is sort of a well-known
characterization of natural policy
gradient the data we run our old policy
we collect examples of state action pair
to observed advantage and so while we're
running our old policy we can either at
each state try every action if we can
reset to that state or we can experiment
using some random action selection and
then use inverse propensity scoring to
correct for our exploration distribution
and in order to calculate the advantage
that's just a baseline right it's it
doesn't matter if it's a biased estimate
if the value we can use any estimate we
want and then once we have this estimate
we do what looks like a boosting step we
just rescale our policy in proportion to
our estimated advantage and
and you can analyze this in the gradient
descent way by showing that this value
estimates the natural gradient therefore
is in an instantaneous improvement
direction or you can attempt to take a
bigger step by convincing yourself that
you have a you have an estimate that is
actually got the good advantage and that
second one it would be a nice research
direction I like in particular a
functional gradient version of the same
algorithm because we can use any
function class we want to try to get a
policy with with better advantage and
what's interesting is that this
algorithm can't get stuck in some sense
right it's a it's a globally optimal
reinforcement learning algorithm because
if you are if you think you're stuck
you're collecting more and more data
from the same policy you can afford to
use more and more complicated function
representations to try and get an
advantage and so eventually you get
unstuck if you weren't optimal it might
take a very very long time right it
might be that you're not visiting the
state that you need to get an accurate
advantage estimate for very often but
you know that's that's that's the breaks
when you're trying to explore in a real
problem right there's no way to get
around that that exploration might take
a long time all right
another example is conservative policy
iteration so this is again well known
algorithm in this case instead of a an
exponential family policy class we have
a mixture policy class we actually use
the exact same way potentially so we do
cost-sensitive classification and one
good cost-sensitive classification
algorithm is to do regression to
estimate the advantages and pick the Arg
max in every state but now once we have
this once we have this estimated
advantage we just do a mixture with the
new policy take a small step so that it
doesn't
doesn't change too much and it turns out
that you can analyze this by showing
that it's a Frank wolf update that
you're you've you've gone to effectively
a corner of the set of representable
policies and you're moving a little bit
towards the best corner which is a Frank
wolf step to get now so these are
algorithms that take small or smallish
steps to get a a bigger step we can make
a connection to imitation learning so
imitation learning is basically just
like RL or just like policy improvement
except we only do one step of policy
improvement at least that's one way to
think of a lot of different imitation
learning algorithms and so we're
actually not trying to do as well as the
expert we're trying to do at least as
well and in fact we might wind up doing
noticeably better which is not something
that people usually point out in the
imitation learning papers but it's it's
an important point so here's an example
of an imitation learning algorithm again
our policy is a mixture a mixture class
we have some base hypothesis space and
we randomized among those policies but
this time our evaluation and improvement
steps are mixed they happen at the same
time we're going to use no regret
classification in other words we're
going to use a learning algorithm which
is aware of the fact that it's training
distribution is changing under it and is
guaranteed to perform well despite that
and once we once we show once we have
that idea it's effectively trivial to
show that we get improvement because we
just run for example we just run our no
regret learner until our no regret
guarantee the error that we have in that
is smaller than the observed improvement
in our policy and we can switch to it
right or we can use the the strategy in
the original aggravate paper which is to
slowly mix from the experts of the learn
policy and you can show if you do that
slowly enough you
you're good all right um so I think I
said most of this already yeah so I
guess I just wanted to point out that
you have a no regret guarantee from
whatever algorithm you're using let's
say online mirror descend and you can
compare that you can precisely calculate
what your expected difference is for
switching and this that's bigger than
your uncertainty then you're good to go
oh and another point is as as the
original paper points out the no regret
learner will come up with a mixture
policy but we can just test each
component of that mixture and use the
best one so there's no reason you can
actually use the base hypothesis space
instead of the mixture and there's a
variant of this that we've experimented
with recently which is kind of nice it
basically throws caution to the wind
right it just throws a deep net in as
your function approximator and is very
aggressive at updating updating your
policy even when you don't have a
guarantee and with those settings even
though you lose the guarantees in
practice it seems to perform really well
so here's an example where we do do
better than the expert so what we did
was we got an expert for demonstration
by running TRP o overnight on one of the
AI gem environments and then we run
[Music]
separately in just a few minutes this
this aggrivated algorithm to try to
imitate that expert and you can see that
our elf from scratch gets nowhere that's
the dotted lines whereas the slot the
solid blue and green lines you know they
start working really well really fast
and eventually actually beat the expert
another nice thing you can do another
nice thing you can do with imitation
learning another nice thing that you can
do with imitation learning is run it on
a pom VP and let the expert cheat right
so
this is a fun way to do RL right your
expert does not have to be active all
your expert could be actually a real
expert who you have to go pay to consult
and you don't have them at test time or
it could be an algorithm that cheats and
peaks at the hidden state of your pom DP
and as long as they're imitatable you're
not going to do better than the expert
but but you can you can do quite well as
shown here and again that flat line at
the bottom is ordinary RL and so at the
time scale of this the ordinary RL has
gotten precisely nowhere alright so what
I wanted to what I wanted to what I
wanted to advocate today is that we look
at look at algorithms within this class
right so there's a ton of combinations
that I haven't had a chance to try and
that you know there's more than I could
possibly try in a lifetime because we
have so many different ways we could
estimate the advantages represent our
step directions or choose to improve our
policies and there's this trade-off from
aggressive to deliberate updates that we
would want to make separately for each
for each new domain but I think it's
it's potentially a really productive
class of algorithms because it holds the
possibility of bringing more information
out of each new sample I also want to be
clear that this is not solving the
exploration problem right this is an
algorithm for doing as well as you can
with the data that you have and we got
to solve the exploration problem right
so I guess I should also advocate that
in parallel we we think about that but
these could I don't know it seems like
if you're able to think more for each
new policy update it's it's potentially
a good
venue for experimenting with exploration
methods all right so I think that's what
I wanted to say so I'll stop there and
thank you and I'll take questions
[Applause]